[Music]
many of you first fell in love with him
on Buffy the Vampire Slayer and then
hung out with him for a dozen plus years
on Fox on bones and now season three of
SEAL team on CBS premieres tomorrow
night at 9:00 Eastern Time every
Wednesday at 9:00 Eastern on CBS
I believe that's America's most watched
Network I hear that during every single
football game the actor David Boreanaz
back here in the program good to see you
sir thank you so much for letting me be
here I love coming here thank you set
and I know that we're premiering
tomorrow and it's it's just great to be
or in an environment like this that's
sports oriented but most importantly the
people that are here that surround you
Wow what it's kind of you know thanks
for coming by David it's like a good
fantasy football crew you know here's
the fantasy stuff we'll get into that
before added to your Eagles in a sec
yeah cuz what what are you so far
through your tune - we just beat Maurice
jones-drew steam okay which i think is a
pretty good hit we've won two
championships in our in our stature
which is so which celebrity NFL
celebrity you in that the NFL celebrity
one huh okay Fabiano's in that one - or
no yeah he seems to always get the
number one pick a weird pick I mean also
my Roenick isn't it do you also have the
same thing with him where he makes a
trade like you were born yesterday
you offers you something like you you
literally we're born on on September
30th and he won on October 1st it's this
whole you know I know fantasy football
so well he may slide something in on you
then you don't agree with it it's kind
of obnoxious I know that happens to me
all the time we're in a celebrity league
with him through Allison chains Wow yeah
through Jerry Cantrell I was gonna be
involved in that one well we need to get
you in there well yeah I would love to I
just I was there was a point in my life
where I was doing three fantasy football
teams at the same time and it was it
took up a lot of energy it is isn't it
it's the hits you get to that point
where now they have that the Thursday
Night Football thing which I think is
crazy yes you have to get all your picks
in on Wednesday you have to you know
dissect them and get all your trades
because I heard it seriously
yes you got waiver wire - look it's a
lot well we've got our championship
trophy to the left are sitting right
there for so we have that
that's cute now if you remember in
thank you from your from your years of
having multiple leagues okay that
there's one that you really want more
than the other right yeah as you want
them all obviously they're greedy but
there's one so I'm in a league with my
poker buddies okay okay and I am
currently Owen for that you need to make
a trade
no I've got I've got Zeke who's been in
the ends only three times okay okay
I've got juju Smith Schuster who's been
poofed by the football gods yeah I've
got Devonta Freeman who has been nothing
short of wildly disappointing statistics
right as well as the Falcons as well
okay Sony Michelle I get we can go on
and on and on and on it was your first
pick my first pick was Zeke at what
number re overall he had just he had
just so I chose him over Christian
McCaffrey
it's not a PR either we picked nine and
we had our first pick was Chubb which we
believe a great week for out of him it's
only gonna get better for the stars of
tomorrow
not for the stars of today okay and I
like it you're a seer you look over the
dashboard David Boreanaz you see well
the name of our team is bolognaise boys
so that should tell you that should tell
you everything you know correspondent in
New Jersey who's very close friend of
mine so tell two photos about those
close friends from New Jersey you know
bring it up to them is that having
dropped to own four yes last night okay
you know I was out it was I was last
night dropped to own four was that a
wonderful party with kids and people for
the Jewish New Year for Rosh Hashanah
and I'm there with my wife and my three
kids and it's a beautiful night and it's
wonderful and I know that I'm gonna come
here and do this show and I'm very
blessed to do this show and game day
morning and all the things you know I'd
literally have to go through a mental
checklist of all the things that aren't
happy and I should be focused on in life
when I'm owing for its so it's beyond
unhealthy uh-huh I literally and I wake
up in the morning and I'm like what's
that oh that's right I'm Owen for in
that league I can't shake it
it's so you have some controversy on
your team it seems like too I mean the
players that you chose a mystery
it's good on paper and the house and
they thought the held out I chose Myles
Sanders I'm waiting for him to come
around for your Eagles which I think
they will I mean I think it's a two back
system with Jordan Howard and Sanders
and I think that's the way Peterson's
running it and I've always professed
like me Jordan Howard is pounding the
ball yes and it finally took him a
couple games for the for Doug Peterson
to really give him the rock because at
first he he didn't give him the rock at
all and it was like this guy gained six
yards of carry well it helps pounder I
guess we should turn the page Jamie goes
David Boreanaz here on the Rich Eisen
show it helps to have a lead either if
you have a lead and you could start
behind those guys Peters and Kelsey man
do I love Kelsey Kelsey was our number
two pick by the way no I'm talking about
your Center okay your Center Jason's
brother Travis is not a bad pick but
that's a good pick I know
wrong again dreams of tomorrow you know
we that should be your new team name I
like that you want to do that but you
know Lane Johnson you get those guys
yeah asserting their theirs themselves
and get Jordan Howard down hill yes play
action out of that you got yourself a
serious offense with Wentz and I think
that you know figuring out the wide
receiver position there with the health
of Deshawn Jackson and you know him
being out and we did that one last week
we didn't really have the wide receivers
we needed and a lot of those wide
receivers that were young we're dropping
passes Nelson Aguilar sorry well you you
saw you saw the video of that Nelson
Thank You Lara did you see the video
that guy selfie was talking about how
he's catching bait unlike a galore but
you see Nelson's response was to give
the guy tickets did you see that of
course he's gonna get him tickets what's
he gonna get him I just like he said you
know a cheesesteak is going on it's like
now it's an Aguilar the ball hits you in
the hands you got to catch it your wife
see if you get paid a lot of money to do
that that's been a bone of contention
for the Eagles organization I think it's
sometime but listen they get paid a lot
of money to catch footballs right that's
your job I mean when's has proven
himself he can you know I'm still can
you stay healthy he rolls her
but man is he a baller well he just not
go ahead first anymore please I mean
like I agree I mean it's interesting
David Boreanaz here on the Rich Eisen
show of week to Sunday night yeah Philly
in Atlanta and I'm again fortunate to do
what I do and and I think I'm up on rule
changes had no idea that in the NFL for
a year now if a quarterback goes
headfirst it's considered giving
yourself up that no more and I learned
that cuz when sweat head first in a game
and they they marked him back a yard
after he had slid safely on normally
back in the day that's where you mark
the ball okay and so now you're
considered giving yourself up where he
went down and I thought to myself well
no remember when I didn't know that rule
number two what the hell is wench doing
he likes to go for those like those if
it's fourth and one he likes to punch it
forward or if it's goal line punch it in
he's a he's just you know that's what
you lose me out though in Los Angeles he
went headfirst into the he's go
headfirst but if you look at that play
his leg tweaked a little bit so it was
the extension of his the force of him
going forward right which really kind of
tweaked that whole knee situation for
him right but again look to his credit
he came back it's tough coming off an
ACL injury he's now in a position where
he's leading his team but he can't do it
all on his shoulders now he's got the
weapons he's got to get healthy which is
the team that concerns you the most uh
you know obviously everybody well
obviously the Cowboys but I mean they
really haven't played a team yet that's
been oh the Saints yes well okay then
they they lost right that's correct okay
so but the first three or two games
first three games they played the
Washington Redskins after the Giants who
didn't have daniel Jones yet and then
the Dolphins I think you know what
honestly I would have to say the Giants
now tell you why I think that's a great
robbery and I really do everyone sits
predictable to say the cowboy isn't I
get it it's gonna be a great game for
the Giants now that they have this
quarterback and everyone's riding this
train on this kid right now who's you
know proven to be pretty good I'm not
saying he wasn't done anything really
yet right but it's it's a spark of
energy for for New York so I think the
Giants and Eagles may end up being some
would not be big games
as far as the NFC's concern I know the
Giants aren't that strong defensively
correct the Eagles have some holes back
in their their second era that need to
clean up and so in their linebacker
situation we just draft traded for this
my wreck from Atlanta I don't even know
who he is
mm-hmm well I mean and that's why you
said you want if Jalen Ramsey's sitting
out that would you want Howie Roseman
you want him to he's a great GM I think
you should give him a call I mean at
this point you mean he wants like a
first maybe I mean they want a lot of
picks for this guy but I he's he's a
shutdown guy David Boreanaz here on the
Rich Eisen show okay season three of
seal team on CBS you shot almost a month
in Serbia for for this season correct
yeah it was a last year we did the show
we shot in Puerto Rico this year we were
you know it was great for us to go to
Serbia and we shot there for almost a
month and I'd say it was a great place
to shoot the people were really friendly
the food is amazing
the the vegetables and the and the
blueberries like they know there's no
pesticide so everything's organic it's
it's absolutely amazing but the assets
that we had they were given to us for
the show we're fantastic my croppers you
know helos and little birds and we did a
great car chase that you're gonna be
seeing ya we're seeing a rhino screen
all shot on the streets and it just
gives to show another dimension which we
hang our hat on is being able to shoot
in these environments that really
challenged us as a team sure we could
have shot in Serbia in Los Angeles
somewhere but I think for our type of
show and the way we shoot it we like
these types of challenges and it makes
it very authentic well it's not just the
realism that you're talking about there
it's also about you know your character
Jase Hayes and others that you you have
on the show as characters who are
dealing with real life yeah issues who
of you what have you learned about the
men and women who fight that is the job
that they do is just unprecedented to
anything and we don't really know about
it and I think the tier-one operators
and we obviously don't know really about
anything what they do and how they
protect and serve the country but when
they come home how debilitating it is
for them to adjust back into society
mm-hmm
you know we can we can have all the you
know the pop and circumstances and
giving back which I think we should do
more of but they go through so much and
they compartmentalize a lot and they
suffer a lot so for me I've been blessed
to be able to play a character like this
and meet these real guys there on set
there on set we work with veterans
whether it's you know in the writers
room or it's you know in the crew or
people in front of the camera the actual
real tier-one guys are the guy who
brought the show to CBS who's a 13
deployments 13 13 captain Phillips you
know the Obama thing everything Osama
bin Laden not Obama yes
across the board just great guys but we
what I learned is underneath it all they
all of these great stories and they
don't really think too much about it
they kind of compartmentalize it and put
it away and when you get to that surface
it's some pretty intense stuff and we
screen these first two episodes for him
three weeks ago and he had to walk out
of the room was very emotional hear him
really there's a sequence where Jason
Hayes has goes through his phone and
he's scrolling through 42 guys and
brothers that he's lost still has him in
his phone and he can't come to grips to
even looking at them and there's a
sequence that happens in these first two
episodes were part of the storyline is
for Jason Hayes his character this year
is to kind of confront a lot of those
demons which he's doing and so yeah he
walked out he couldn't deal with it and
so I'm blessed to be able to be a part
of that and be able to show that and and
cast some light into these shadows these
are what these what these men and women
go through season three of SEAL team on
CBS premieres tomorrow night at 9:00
Eastern Time its Wednesdays at 9:00
Eastern you can follow David on Twitter
David Boreanaz with a an underscore in
between David and Boreanaz like a seer
and that's right and on Instagram at D
Gbagbo 69 correct
Bob Manor II would be very happy I'm
mentioning Bob because he's a friend of
ours and just the fact that I'm
mentioning Bob yes the Instagram
percentage goes
I'd say at least I mean I'm giving a big
shout out to Bob mentoring Bob mentoring
can I get my single for that as well
just in case yeah at Rich Eisen the
Instagram numbers can go up hey Bob how
are you Bob how do you know Bob
mentoring because you know I did i did i
did a an episode of billions with him oh
wow so you actually were there and you
actually I just I started following him
I like the guy I comment and all of a
sudden he started following me and we
kind of two of us kind of headed out a
little bit with the barstool guy stoolie
president okay guy all right but we got
through that controversy or through it
we're through it okay you know one bite
one bite everybody knows the rules guy
that guy okay and and did you get Bob
through his bosses gonna crush me that's
alright you got a guy who knows exactly
what I'm talking about the Ripper
Magoo's David okay there you go
your baby's walked out of this room my
account has gone from five hundred to
five million followers
snapper Oney but he's a guy that you
know honestly yeah you know it is what
it is and I'm excited that we're in
October and there's those Flyers
there you go you know it's it's it's a
great time of the year college football
that's right cause everything is I know
October's a great great time if only
your Phillies were in the playoffs for
you too Sixers tipping off you go drop
the Phillies I it's all right from now
it's a true thing if he or if they only
worry would be a better month for you
who's yours baseball team the New York
Yankees
I like the Yankees enjoy October joying
the Yankees run tell it seriousiy miss
sounds way too
argumentative right now and we're really
on the same page it's like a fantasy
football team fantasy leagues against
teal team on CBS season 3 premieres
tomorrow at 9:00 Eastern Time
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on Br
live or download the Rich Eisen show app